foreign
in the early hours of Thursday February
24th Russia launched airstrikes on
Ukraine and sent troops and military
equipment over the border from Belarus
to Crimea
many of the first troops came through
Ukraine's Northeastern border with
Russia a line of attack that was weeks
in the making
The Wall Street Journal analyzed dozens
of satellite images captured by maxar
Technologies and Planet Labs verified
videos posted to social media and found
that the Russian troops and military
equipment that came in from the East had
moved out of large visible garrisons and
dispersed into smaller harder to track
units along the border before they
attacked
Russia had been amassing troops and
equipment near Ukraine for weeks which
they said were for military exercises
satellite images from a camp in yanya
Russia show a military training area
being built up images from January 19th
show that the camp had expanded and that
it was active these tents are not snow
covered a sign that they were likely
being heated
tombolic an intelligence expert who
analyzed these images identified bm-27
aragans which are multiple rocket
launcher systems
battalions made up of what are likely
2s-19s vehicles with guns designed to
shoot shells long distances and
battalions of what look to be infantry
fighting vehicles but by February 12th
the area had mostly emptied out
around the same time satellite images
show troops and Equipment building up in
several regions closer to the Russian
Ukrainian border at a training area east
of korsk satellite imagery from February
9 shows a line of empty heavy equipment
Transporters likely waiting to be loaded
with tanks then four days later on
February 13th we can see the Camp which
Bullock says had expanded in size
significantly over the past few weeks
was active the overturned dirt signals
people and Equipment were moving around
also on the 13th we see Russian military
presence in two other key locations
close to the Ukraine border in the
briansk region we see climavo air base
where a new grouping of tents were
visible again with signs they were being
heated in salati which is a campused
regularly by the Russian military we see
a new field camp and signs of movement
in the snow
north of Belgrade we can see a
helicopter camp with more than 12 attack
and transport helicopters and on
February 15th in value key we see
another field of attack Choppers
on February 15th Russian officials
signaled they were de-escalating and
withdrawing some troops from the
Ukrainian border
over the following days cloudy weather
obstructed views of many key border
locations from satellite images but
videos posted to social media suggest a
continued March of soldiers and
Equipment towards the border with
Ukraine from these positions the
Ukrainian city of harkif was in Striking
Distance and more troops could quickly
be added to the donbos region the
Ukrainian capital of Kiev is about 300
miles from the border this video from
Belgrade which the poster said they
filmed on February 15th shows a train
traveling Southwest towards the Border
carrying various equipment from the 4
division including toad howitzers which
shoot artillery shells
a video posted February 16th from
Belgrade shows the fourth tank division
heading south near the border Bullock
says they likely came straight from
Moscow which is significant because it's
highly unusual for them to be so far
outside their regular training area
on February 16th in tamarovka an attack
helicopter was filmed while landing at a
civilian Airfield experts have also
identified a short-range air defense
system Bullock says it was partially
obscured by a tarp a sign of camouflage
not storage and that it was in a
position to be used a day later a video
posted on February 17 roughly 16 miles
from the Ukraine Border in rylsk shows
Russian military vehicles including a
heavy equipment transporter with a tank
then in a video posted the next day on
February 18th we returned to tamarovka
where Bullock first identified an air
defense system
he says that on the air defense system
in this clip the radar which can be seen
here was in use
in the same video we see t90a tanks
positioned on the edge of the woods
facing the road indicating Vehicles may
have started to disperse further into
wooded areas out of sight
in videos like this one posted in
Belgrade on February 18th we see
markings that experts suspect to
identify Russian vehicles or convey
other tactical information
satellite images from February 21st and
22nd show how troops moved into remote
camps where land is likely being cleared
for additional troops and we can see a
new field Hospital added to a Garrison
on the outskirts of Belgrade suggesting
possible casualties to come
foreign